I think I said to him the
first time that I walked into this just
I don't know what it is about this
this job
or this calling to be a storyteller,
but I know every time
I come into it with me
and then I leave and something's
different, something's changed,
and it's hard to necessarily
say what that is,
but every single person here,
the heart that you've put into it,
it's completely changed me
as a human being.
I feel like I have a home here,
which I'll be back to quite a bit.
And I've said it to several of you too
in conversation,
it's not since I was a teenager
renting out basement
spaces in art galleries
just making sh*t with my friends
for the sake of doing it
have I felt such equal
and open and loving collaboration
and craftsmanship,
which is something
something pretty remarkable at this level
because this is this is a first for me.
But yeah,
I believe in every storyteller here.
I believe in every craftsperson
here. I believe
in every beating heart and soul here.
This is really special.
Thank you all so much
for bringing everything to this.
And I'll remember it forever.
And we'll all have it forever.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you all.